hey what's up I'm Jackie and I'm Kevin
today we're going to be drawing random
characters in our own style from Allah
we're without you
that's how drawing works every morning I
come to work and I spin this wheel and
that's what I do for the day well it's
so not dramatic okay
scooby-doo okay let's get to it
okay so I like their car that they drive
so I'm gonna just have her driving a car
I'm gonna do an action shot that's gonna
be like fast and furious Wilma so tell
me about tracer so tracer is like the
poster girl for overwatch her thing is
that she's fast so she's like pretty
thin her she's petite she has a spiky
short black hair she has like these cute
little orange leggings so Velma is a
nerd oh who solves mystery it's that's
all you need to know about Velma
since suddenly I was like getting all
self-conscious like what's my style how
do I draw what am i what it would have
been flying light here on earth what
does it mean to be an artist I don't
know I'm just gonna draw and that's
gonna be my style but I'm just gonna
make em really cartoony and angry like
this drawing is really gonna evil you
talked to my swarm I loved watching
Bob's Burgers when I watched it I
haven't seen it in a while though yeah
it's still going right yeah it's a great
great show it's so like undercover funny
like they set up jokes and you're like
oh I'm gonna sound like such an old man
but his tracer your main whoa I got it I
said it right right love that that was
such a lovely little surprise from Kevin
right what's up fellow youths so Linda
Linda has actually a great silhouette
hair has like this kind of Mary Tyler
Moore thing going on I might be getting
that wrong I guess you can correct
people can correct me and she has no
chin but I'm gonna draw her with a chin
just cuz Chin's make sense to me
3d characters versus 2d it's like
interesting when you try to draw them
exactly how they look in 3d sometimes it
might not quite look right cuz it's just
no realistic character like Shrek I'm
gonna draw thin like he's had one too
many adventures the gravy reboot all
these ladies are so like voluptuous and
all the dudes are fat like these women
could do better I'm just gonna say it
wasn't weren't the Flintstones just
cavemen version of the honeymooners I
don't even know because we don't have a
lot of time are you doing anything to
simplify or change the character no I
hope the internet knows that we only
have like 20 minutes to do this yeah
they don't care yeah they want us to
suffer they're like well why didn't you
draw it like this
well you know what why don't you come
here and you try to do this there's a
lot of stress in them I kind of go
between like 2d and 3d space so I'm just
adding I guess a little more volume to
this character I think I'm going for
like I love the comic-book style I
decided this time to go for even more
movement even though the character is
not designed that way we're using this
type of device called a Cintiq which is
a scream that you can draw directly on
Photoshop is also just a fantastic
program because you could do so much in
it they keep optimizing it you know
there's also like a free alternative you
can use such as [ __ ] yeah which is very
similar to photoshop I think it might
even work with something still - no
matter how little of tools you have you
can be a great artist it's just practice
what are some tips that you would have
for people if they wanted to learn how
to draw
faster just draw faster okay that's not
a tip the most important thing is to
draw from life I mean everybody will
tell you this and that is by far the
most important thing to learn is that
good good advice
well here's that some real advice learn
some short hands for things you know
people know what hands look like right
you don't have to make it so detailed
for people to know what a hand is right
true in animation you see a lot of
cartoons where they don't even have five
fingers that doesn't look like a human
hand really but you know it's a hand
because you know what hands look like
keep it up kid
you can do whatever you put your mind to
he's grown up his clothes don't really
fit them as well as they used to so
belly sticking out so where is Jake I
don't know it's kind of a messy thing
it's their Facebook it says it's
complicated so here is how I shade my
drawings I just make a new layer on top
of the color I set the transfer mode to
soft light and then I use a hundred
percent black to paint into darker
colors it's a little pro tip for you
there Jackie Thanks you take that home
you ingest it you use it in the future
Justin what I do is I try all of my
drawing as line art on one layer and
then I do the painting as a separate
layer underneath so kids layers are your
friend I like mine I think like I said
it looks very cartoony even more so than
the actual cartoon I dig it nice all
right
confidence is key yeah all right you
ready swap let's swap swap
oh don't dude what a dynamic pose yeah I
mean same for you then I like the car
looks like a part of her outfit oh my
god is just like too much adventures wow
this is really cool thanks Jackie this
is amazing I like this because it's
different than your normal style like I
feel like your style is usually very
cheesy and very like very cute this has
still got that like cute appeal to it
but it's way more realistic I like yours
yours is like more than cute I think
it's more of like a comic version right
like if there is like a comic strip more
comedy based yeah scooby-doo comic strip
this would be her okay dude yours and
mine are both like they're come to
clashing they're coming at ya they are
coming at each other yeah yeah I like
the changes you made she looks more mad
like man mad hat like I'm not like angry
besides the obvious improvement next
level I think it was a lot of fun you
know like getting to really take
characters that you know and love and
and draw it in your own style I mean I
think that's why so many people do so
much fan art of stuff because it is fun
to take these characters and do your own
take on them this you know this was fun
I wish I had more time but I think I did
what I could and you know I wish you
know tracer was wearing one shirt
but it'd be like that sometimes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]